The Opposition
is on high alert.
I'm talking threat level red,
DEFCON one, diaper full.
Now, obviously, we all know why.
This week, one of the most
influential organizations
in the world launched an attack
against everything
we thought we knew.
TV REPORTER: The International
House of Pancakes
is flipping it's "P" for a "B.”
IHOP, announcing on Twitter,
that it will now be called
"IHOB"
and will explain why on Monday.
Some people are downright
outraged.
Grace tweeting, "someone sue
IHOP for changing their name.
What kind of anarchy is this?”
Yeah.
This is anarchy!
I haven't been this rattled
by a threat
since Gloria Estefan said
"the rhythm is gonna get you.”
I've got to admit-- I'm still a
little skittish around congas.
IHOP, the letter that was broken
in your name wasn't the "P.”
It was the "I" for
"international.”
I hate the fact that my
create-a-face pancake is made
in a globalist enclave full of
espionage and French toast.
Opposers,
we can't wait till Monday.
We need to know what
in God's name IHOB is planning,
because the mainstream media
isn't going to help us
through this crisis.
All their ideas are terrible.
TV REPORTER: The best guess
is that it will become
the International House
of Breakfast.
TV REPORTER: No official word
yet on what that "B"
will stand for; although,
it's thought to be "breakfast.”
TV REPORTER:
The most common--
and our producers think
the most likely--
is, of course, "breakfast.”
It's gonna be "breakfast,"
IHOB.
First off, thanks, MSM
for covering this hard news.
(laughter)
But you're absolutely wrong.
It can't be breakfast.
That's what the "B"
in Cardi B stands for...
Cardi Breakfast.
If Wikipedia disagrees,
change it.
I dare you.
Besides, breakfast would be
too simple, too obvious,
too undeserving
of an entire ad campaign
with a full week's lead-in
to the rollout.
It has to be something else.
All hands on deck.
Citizen journalist Laura Grey--
IHOB, what is the "B"?
Easy, Jordan.
Say hello to the International
House of Benghazi
with today's special dish:
the rooty, tooty fresh n'
Hillary did it!
Right.
So, you're all in on Benghazi?
Aren't you, Jordan?
Aren't we all?
Yes, of course, Laura.
Tim Baltz, what is the "B"?
Jordan, it's clear the feminists
are behind this.
Why else would they remove
the "P" for "penis"
and replace it with a "B"
for "bagina.”
(laughter)
You realize...
vagina starts with a "V," right?
Impossible.
If it's not the feminists,
then why does the "OB"
in the new IHOB logo look
exactly like the secret logo...
(laughter)
on the secret box that only
my mother and sister
were ever allowed to touch?
Little did they know,
I used to steal them
and turn them into very soft
nunchucks for my G.I. Joes.
No bad ideas, Tim.
Josh, Aaron, what is the "B"?
Jordan, the "B"
is just phase one.
Next, they're gonna take the "H"
and twist it around.
Then turn the "O" sideways
so it becomes an "I.”
And change the "B" into an "S"
just because.
And, suddenly, IHOB is...
KLEPPER:
ISIS. ISIS.
Exactly, Jordan.
The terrorists are playing
a long game.
They're going to slowly kill us
over the next 40 years
with high-carb,
high-sugar breakfasts.
The terrorists are gonna win
through diabetes, Jordan!
Oh, this is worse
than I thought.
It's a full on "ihopalypse.”
(cheering and applause)
We will be on this story
all week
because we only have five days
left to crack this code.
And I swear to God, it better
not be "breakfast.”
I'm (bleep) serious, IHOB.
Sit your syrupy ass down
and hear me when I say,
if that "B" just stands for
(bleep) breakfast,
I'm going to come down there,
tear the blue roof right off
your globalist pancakery,
put your short stacks in
the waffle maker,
and send you back to whatever
hash brown hell you came from.